[موسيقى]
اهلا ومرحبا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام
عند مرافعه الجزائر انصحوا وصفها كذلك
امام مجلس حقوق الانسان التابعي للامم
المتحده في جنوب وسط انتقادات تاره
الناعمه وطورا لاذعه لسجلها الحقوقي
ودعوات لها لمراجعه بعض من تشريعاتها
وممارساتها بما يتلائم مع التشريعات
الدوليه المنظمه لحقوق الانسان مشاهدينا
الكرام
اهلا ومرحبا وشكرا على تربيه الدعوه
مرحبا كل الترحيب وانت ايضا كل ترحيب
بضيفي من الجزائر
العاصمه ارجو ان يسعف الاسكايب هذا المساء
سيد موسى ابو دهان استاذ القانون الدستوري
والبرلماني السابق اهلا بك ومرحبا استاذ
موسى ابو دهان وشكرا جزيلا لك ايضا على
تربيه الدعوه
اهلا وسهلا شكرا جزيلا للشباب تحيه لكم
مشاهدي قناه المحترمه ولي ضيفك الكريم
مرحبا بك كل الترحيب امم ربما في انتظارنا
نطرح سؤال على
ضيفي نواصل ترتيبات الصوره من الجزائر
العاصمه في انتظارتها عليكم هذا السؤال
الرئيسي اذا كما تابعتما تابع كثيرون وزير
العدل الجزائري عام مشيدا بجوده بلاده
والتزامها همم
بحقوق الانسان مدافع عن ايضا عن خياراتها
التشريعيه تلقى العديد من الاسئله من
ممثلي الدول الغربيه في مجلس حقوق الانسان
بجناف همم
المجلس حقوق الانسان الاممي ورد عليها حول
قضايا حقوقيه عديده وسؤال كيف بدا لكم
تقييم هذه الدول للسجل الحقوقي للجزائر هل
اقنعت الجزائر ام ان الممارسات الفعليه
تتنافى مع الخطاب
المسوق من طرف السلطه كما يقول المنتقدون
اطرح عليك سؤال
اولا ضيفي من الجزائر العاصمه سيد موسى
ابو دهان استاذ القانون الدستوري
والبرلماني السابق مرحبا من جديد
لسجل الجزائر الحقوقي في مجلس حقوق
الانسان في جناب كيف تابعته
وايضا هل اقنعت الجزائر هل اقنع وزير
العدل في الدفاع عن حصيله بلادها الحقوقيه
استاذ موسى
والله تعودنا على على ان ثماتها منظمات
غير غير رسميه انها
تعلق كثير على ما يدريك في صحن الوطنيه
وخاصه ثم يتعلق منها
بحمايه وترقيه حقوق الانسان وحريته وما
الى ذلك كما تعود معينا على ان ثم دول
شقيقه وصديقه ومن خلال
المختلفه وجمعيات
الجزائر وبالتالي نحن لا لا لا تضرنا تلك
الاصوات نعيقه هنا وهناك ال ال المنتقده
لوضعيه حقوق الانسان في الجزائر نحن
ملتزمون بكل المواثيق والاعلانات والسقوق
والالاتفاقيه المتعلقه
بحقوق بحقوق الانسان سواء منها الحقوق
الاقتصاديه او الاجتماعيه او الثقافيه او
السياسيه او نحوها وكما ايضا
خاصه الدستور نوفمبر 2020 في حوالي 4 اكثر
في الحقيقه اكثر من 44 ماده كلها تتحدث عن
حقوق الاساسي والحريات العامه
في الجزائر ومنها الحقوق المتعلقه بانشاء
الحزاب السياسيه والحقوق المتعلق او
الحريات والحقوق المتعلقه بانشاء الجمعيات
والتبسيط الاجراءات المتعلقه بها واا ايضا
ضمان ضمان حمايتها من كل تعسف وخاصه مثلا
حلها او تقييدها او تجميدها او الى ذلك
هذه الامور صارت لا يمكن ان تتم الا عبر
الى عبر اجراءات القضائيه واضحه وضوح
الشمس ثم اليوم لمعلوماتكم همم في الجزائر
ستنعقيد ال- ال- الطبعه الثالثه للجلسات
الوطنيه المتعلقه بالمجتمع المدني وبضرور
تكريس الحقوق والحريات الخاصه
هذا المجتمع المدني المتكون عندنا في
الجزائر من اكثر من من من من
200,000 او 1500 على الاقل 150,000 جمعيه
بين جمعيه وطني ومحليه من مختلف
الرياضيه والاجتماعيه والثقافيه
والاقتصاديه ونحوها قلت اليوم نحن سنعيش
او غدا طبعا غدا وبعد غدي سنعيش همم جلسات
وطنيه خاصه واضح سيد موسى ابو دهان همم
ولعلنا فما تتقطع اسف لدى مشاهدينا الكرام
على التقاطع التاره على الصوره من همم
الجزاء اللي ربما نحاول ان نجد حالا لهذا
الاهتزاز الطائر على الصوره نعتذر لدى
مشاهدينا الكرام ربما في انتظار ترتيب هذه
الاموره
سياسي والحقوقي هل نجح وزير العدل في
الجزائري في الدفاع عن سجل بلاده الحقيقي
ام ان ربما خطابه لم يغير المعطيات
الموجوده لدى هذه الهيئه
الامميه وكيف تبعت ايضا تقييم الدول
النظام الجزائري
للاسف يفر من سماع النصيحه وينشط لسماع
الفضيحه كذلك كان الامر في هذا التقييم
همم الذي همم يعني حدث في جنيف والذي تعرض
اليه الوفد الجزائري هذا الامتحان العسير
وهذه الانتقادات القويه التي تعرضها اليها
الوفد الجزائري وعلى راسهم وزير العدل
وحافظ الاختام واا يعقب على ما قال ضيفك
انه قال في الدول الصديقه هنئت الجزائر
انا سمعت الرئيس عبد المجيد تبون يقول ان
الولايات المتحده دوله صديقه للجزائر
والولايات المتحده كانت اشد
الدول
المنتقدين ل همم سياسه حقوق الانسان في
الجزائر
اا واقر
وزير العدل الجزائري حافظ الاختام امام
هيئه الدول
امام هيئه الدول
الامم المتحده لحقوق الانسان اقرب لسانه
عن وجود متابعات سياسيه لنشطاء وحقوقين
قال فقط انها قليله ولكن يقر بانها موجوده
وبهذا يناقد ما قاله الرئيس عبد المجيد
لما قال ان اكذوبه القرن فانا اسال السؤال
التالي هل يبقى الوزير ويرحل الرئيس او
يبقى الرئيس ويرحل الوزير فقط وسعود على
ذلك
سيد همم سمير يحياوي انه نفى وجود ما يسمى
بجريمه الراي والصحافه او عقوبه سالب
الحريه بالنسبه للمهنيين والاعلاميين في
اطار ممارسه مهام يقول البقيه لا علاقه
لهم بحريه
العداله فقط وزير الوعد قالوا قال ان
المتابعات السياسيه
قليله ومن فضلك اعطيني حكيم الوقت الذي
اعطي بس خبر
متوسطه
يعني في في اشياء لازم نقولها ساعود اليك
ساعطيك نفس هذه الوقت
اعود الى ضيف من الجزائر العاصمه ارجو
منها ان همم لا تكون الاجابه مطوله هنا
يحيي السيد موسى
البرماني همم السابق سالفه هل نجح همم سيد
وزير العدل في الدفاع عن سجل بلاده همم
ولكن صراحه الاشكاليه بالنسبه لبعض الدول
هي ان الجزائر تبعت باشارات سلبيه همم سيد
موسى ابو دهان من ذلك تاجيل زياره المقرر
الخاصه للامه المتحده المعني بحريه
التظاهر السلميه وتاسيس جمعيات والنقابات
لعام 2003 على ما يبدو هو تاجيل الثامن من
نوع منذ 2011 بالاضافه الى ان الارقام لا
تخطئ ابدا يوجد في البلاد يقول الحقوقيون
حوالي 250 سجين رايي هم اتهمون في كثير من
الاحيان بالارهاب العشرات من الناشطين
تبعوا فقط بسبب منشورات على فيسبوك صح-
صحفيين دخلوا السجن بسبب مقالات وكتابات
وتبعوا على اساس قانون العقوبات يقول
دائما الحقوقيون همم في حكم مرافعاتهم
امام مجلس حقوق الانسان على الرغم من ان
الدستور يمنع العقوبه سالبه للحريه في حق
الصحفي والانتقاد الله كما كان يقول ضيفي
اتى من الولايات المتحده خلال هذه الجلسه
كيف ترد على كل همم ذلك
اقول باختصار شديد ان انتقاد دوله او
اثنين او ثلاثه او اكثر لا لا يضر لان
الاغلبيه ساحقا من الدول الشقيقه وصديقه
كما قلت واكرر انها في الحقيقه ثمنه تقرير
الجزائر بخصوص المتعلق
بحقوق وحريه الانسان في في الجزائر همم
الان القول بان بان ثمه همم ثم همم
اشخاص يعني
تمت متابعتهم على اساس على اساس جريمه ما
يسمى بجريمه الراي والشيء من القبيل اقول
بان بعض الاخوان بعض الزملاء بعض الاصدقاء
وانت صحفي وتعرف ذلك همم يعتقدون بان حريه
الصحافه ان ان ان ان ان لا نفعل ما نشاء
ان انا نذهب الى استعمال الخطب الكراهيه
خطب التمييز خطبه الجهويه
والحاقه ضرر بالغير الاساس بكرامته الاساس
شمعتهم ويظنون بان هذه صحراء هذه حريه
الراي وهذه هي حره التظاهر وهذه حره
التجمع وهذه الحريه الاخرى ال- همم نخطئ
نخطئ اذا اعتقدنا بان باننا لما نخلط ان
صح التعبير بين جريمه الراي
والمعتقد وما الى ذلك مع مع جريمه القانون
العام التي يتصدى لها قانون العقوبات هذا
من من من اللواء
الكبير طيب
تستانف من حيث قطعته عفوا وتصريحات همم
وزير العدل الجزائري امام مجلس حقوق
الانسان بجناف تاتي ايضا في سياق تصريحات
الرئيس الجزائري الذي تحدث عن كذبه القرن
حين همم تم الطرق لمساله المعتقليه الراي
او المعتقلين السياسيين همم في همم الجزاء
وهو يجيب عقب ايضا على ضيفه وهو يجيب على
رساله مكتوبه وجهت له من طرف ااا
ليشتنشتاين والولايات المتحده وقال ردا
على هذه الرساله ان المتابعات القضائيه ضد
النشطاء السياسيين والحقوقيين قليله يقول
قليله وغير ولين في يعني وجودها وهذا
يناقد رئيس الجمهوريه عبد المجيد التبوني
اذى قلت هل يبقى الرئيس ويذهب الوزير او
يبقى الوزير او يذهب الرئيس ليعاقب على
المقاله همم ضيفك الكريم يقول الدول
القليله ساكرها هذه الدول القليله
الولايات المتحده بريطانيا المانيا النمسا
هولندا الدنمارك استراليا سويسرا اسبانيا
النرويج لتونيا لاذكر الا هذه الدول التي
انتقدت بشده سياسه السياسه الجزائريه حقوق
الانسان فيما يخص بشكل عام فيما يخص ايضا
حقوق المراه
حوريه الصحافه الاسبوع الماضي
زميلكم القاضي يحسن
في الارهاب يعني هذا رئيس
راديو ان وجريده الكترونيه تدعى بمقلب
ايميرجو وجهه له تهمه بانه يعني
تم ارهابيه تحت القانون
787 مكرر الذي طالبه المدرسه
بوتان
لا تتحدث لو سمحت حين يكون ضيفي يتحدث ان
لا احد سيستمع اليه في جمله واحده حتى لو
سمحت كل ما اذكره ليست ارقامي ليست ارقام
سمير يحياوي هي ارقام المنظمات الجزائريه
لحقوق الانسان والمنظمات الدوليه على
راسها الامم المتحده والمنظمات الغير
الحكوميه طيب السيد بدهان سيتعاقب على ما
ذهب اليه ضيفه ولكن فعلا ممثله الولايات
المتحده انتقدت هذه الماده وهي امامي 87
مكرر المستحدث عام 2020 في قانون العقوبات
والتي توسع مفهوم الارهاب نحو اي فعل من
شانه ربما تغيير نظام الحكم دعات الى
اطلاق لصلاح الصحفيين والمدافعين عن حقوق
الانسان والمحتاجين بموجب هذه الماده التي
ادت الى محاكمه عدد كبير من نشيط الحراك
بتهمه الارهاب التنميه لانه تم الافراج
عنهم جميعا في الاونه الاخيره تفضل ضيفي
سيد مدهال همم
استاذنا الفاضل اولا همم نحن دوله حره
مستقله ولا يمكن ان نقبل باي املاء من اي
طرف امكان فاذا لماذا
تتوجه
في الامم المتحده
تفضل عفوا عن المقاطع
تنطبق على كل الافعال المتعلقه بالعمليات
الارهابيه وبالارهاب فهذا يقول ايضا فيه
نظر ذلك ان ال- همم الارهاب معرف وان كان
تعريفه يعني من المسائل التي يعني صعوبه
على الفقهاء والقانون والرجال القانون وما
لذلك لكن عموما نحن في الماده 77 مكرر
حصرنا الاعمال الارها في مسائل مخبوطه
ومحدده ولا يمكن ان نتجاوز هذه المفاهيم
متعلقه بالارهاب ثم ايضا ال- ال- الذي
يريد ان يحاسبنا على تكيف وقائع معينه
بانها من افعال الارهاب او من غير ذلك
فهذا في الحقيقه همم يتدخل في شؤوننا نحن
لدينا قلنا سياده كامله في في في اقتصادنا
وفي سياستنا وفي ديبلوماسيتنا وفي كل
امورنا وفي تشريعنا همم لا يمكن ان تاتي
اي دوله من الدول وتقول بانها اتفاقيات
ارجوك
لنا السياده الكاميرا في اعداد النصوص
ضيفنا المحترم قلت اذا نحن اسياد في سن
السياسه سريع السياسه العقابيه اللازمه
ونقول وذا الجريمه والعقوبه سامحني نحن
لدينا مبدا في سياستنا الجنائيه خاصه في
قانون العقوبات همم هذا المبدا تقول فيه
العديد من المواد القانون القانون
العقوبات انه لا جريمه ولا عقوبه الا
بنصيب وبالتالي لا يمكن يعاقب شخص ما وان
يصلي على العقوبه او نردين اهو بيغير نصين
قانوني طيب
تعود الى ضيفه لو سمحت سيد بودهان فقط
الماده امامي وهي تشمل حتى الاعتداء على
رموز الامه والجمهوريه النابشه والتدنيس
القبور على قله حركه المرور وحريه التنقل
في الطرق والتجمر او الاعتصام في الساحات
العموميه ووزير الدفاع العدل العفوا يقول
بل قال امام مجلس حقوق الانسان دافع عن
هذه الماده من قانون العقوبات يقولون مساج
مع قرارات مجلس الامن ولا يوجد تعريف موحد
الارهاب ما يترك للدول وهذا الامر سياسي
الذي تحدث عنه ضيفه ما يترك للدور الحريه
لتحديد ما يمكن هضمنا الفعل
ارهابي تعقب على مذهب اليه ضيفه هذا هو
المخيف في الامر لان هيئه الامم المتحده
تعطي يعني تفسير واضح لما هو العمل
الارهاب وعندنا وزير لعدل يخطئ في
تصريحاته امام هيئه الامم المتحده وقله ما
فيش يعني دي ما كاش تعريف بالارهاب
التعريف موجود وواضح والقانون 87
مكرر الماده الماده الماده 87 مكرر
تتهم بالايراب حتى الناس للطالب بالتغيير
النظام
الجزائري
بسلميه
لي اين اقول ان اضيفك يخطئ ويخطئ الراي
العام
الدستور الجزائري
ان القوانين الدوليه التي مضت عليها
الجزائر
ويعني التحقت بها هي فوق القوانين العضويه
والقوانين الداخليه للجزائر وعلى القضاه
ان يطبق هذا يعني يطبقونه ان القوانين
الدوليه التي التحقت بها الجزائر تفوق
القوانين العضويه والقوانين الداخليه لهذا
اقول لا نخطئ المجتمع
الراي العام ولما يقول لم يقول نحن
ذاتياده ان كان
فلماذا يذهب
ويعني يتوجه نحو هذا الامتحان يرفضوا
ويقول هذه الامم انا بديش بيكم وندير واش
نحب في الجزائر هذا هو الخطا هذا ما لم
تقوله الجزائر وهذا من هذا اقول
سياده التعامل
بها انه مستعد اتفاقي
هذا الرئيس
كل النصوص والمواسير والاتفاقيات والسقوط
الدوليه
بكل هذه الكلمه من معاني وابعاد وما
مفاهيم فاذا لا احد بامكانه ان ان ان
يدرسنا
يعطينا دروس في هذه المساله قوانينا
منسجمه مع الاتفاقيات والمعاد الدوليه
دستورنا وهو ابي القوانين لابد ان يسمعوا
على هذه الاتفاقيات والمعاذه الدوليه
في الديباجه في ديباج الدستور خاصه
الدستور 2020 تحدثنا في ديباجه على ان
الجزائر ملتزمه بكل هذه النصوص والقوانين
كما قال وظيفه وان كانت في الحقيقه عده
يطلق بعد اتفاقيات وبالتالي همم
القوات نعم صحيح همم يلتزمون بتطبيق ال
همم تطبيق الاتفاقيات الدوليه وهي في
الحقيقيه
لما لما هي تسموا على القوانين الداخليه
هذا صحيح بينص الماده اعتقد همم 55 من همم
ااا او 155 من الدستور التي تقول بامن
الاتفاقيه المعادات التي يصادق عليها
تسموا على القوانين الوطني هذا لا خبر
عليه ولكن في المقابله همم
التوضيح ولكن انت ايضا يا اخي المحترم
ممكن اقول ممكن ممكن
اقولها كلمه الختام شاهد العالم
في الجزائر ونسيت ونسيت المئات من العشرات
حتى لا اقول مئات من الدول الاخرى التي
سندت وعيدت وكل جهود الجزائر يقول لك تنسى
الدول التي تم نجود الجزائر وتختم رايناها
لها
نظامها يشبه النظام الجزائري فلذا ساندته
العالم كله على المباشر الامتحان الاسير
الذي تعرض اليه الوفد الجزائري والفشل في
الدفاع الوزير في الدفاع عن ذلك
لان الامور واضحه والارقام الارقام
التي اقولها التي تقولها المنظمات
الداخليه في الجزائر والمنظمات الدوليه
والمنظمات الحقوقيه والغير الحكوميه هي
التي ذكر فيها
متعلق بالحساب الجمعيات المواطنين وهذه
قوانين و و مواد سترى النور قريبا تم
العمل عليها في الجزائر في المرحله حاليا
وهذا ما قاله وزير العدل الجزائري كل شبه
الجزيره لكما في الاسود السيد سمير يحيى
والنشط السياسي والحقوق شكرا جزيلا كلنا
شوف جزيلا لك ايضا من الجزائر العاصمه سيد
موسى ابو دهان السيد القانون الدستوري
والبرلماني السابق شكرا جزيلا لكما على
المشاركه شكرا لكم على المتابعه كنتم معنا
في فقره وجهان